en mars 2011 nassimah dindar est élu une
nouvelle fois la tête de l'institution
qui s'appelle encore conseil général
elle est aux côtés de paul vergès
l'homme qui l'a aidé à ce moment-là a
continué son engagement auprès des
réunionnais bien évidemment je suis venu
remercier les partenaires politiques que
j'ai eu à titre personnel paul vergès
homme politique qui a traversé ici les
grands moments de l'histoire
il est aux côtés de la présidente le 6
avril dernier au collège bourbon pour
rendre hommage au soldat français
originaire de la réunion déportés
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale tk
jamais notre hobby
ça m'a rajeuni des catalanes parce que
c'est bien cette cour jardin des années
qui virent région je vis les dix pattes
et beaucoup d'autres et ceux qui étaient
dans ma place même embarras les ont
menés 26 pendant des années d'arrêt
après cette vente et balma officielle
d'une plaque à la mémoire dans la zone
qui connaissent une décision qu'on entre
nick jonas qui est exemplaire
héroïque et qui doit servir d'exemple à
tous les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ils
assumer les conséquences qu'il était
emprisonné torturé sûrement dépend t il
à risquer la mort j'étais fidèle
c'est pourquoi il est un exemple pour
les jeunes c'est un honneur et puis on
retrouve paul vergès dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source pour les 70 ans de
la départementalisation pour avoir la
légalité charles il a fallu attendre 50
ans
et pour l'obtenir il a fallu que les
waro et moi-même quand nous étions
débuté
nous avons publiquement démissionner à
l'assemblée nationale en disant nous ne
resterons plus dans cette assemblée de
temps qu'on attend
moi
c'est vrai qu'on a eu mais 50 ans après
c'est grâce à nous c'est à l'école où
vous aurez accusés ou danser malonga de
jeunesse c'était interdit
il ya quelques dizaines d'années qui va
imposer c'est palpable chez nous